in a regular tetrahedron and that's just
a four-sided polyhedron and it's regular
so all of the sides and all the faces
will be the same the centers of the four
faces are the vertices of a smaller
tetrahedron the ratio of the volume of
the smaller tetrahedron to that of the
larger is m over n where m and n are
relatively prime positive integers
find m plus n so let's just draw this
regular tetrahedron first so this is a
regular tetrahedron so in order to have
four equal sides or four equal faces i
should say in three dimensions it needs
to look like this it essentially needs
to be
three and this essentially needs to be
four triangles
so we have one triangle just like that
then we have another triangle like that
then we have another triangle in the
back so this is another triangle in the
back and then we have a triangle as a
base this is a regular tetrahedron where
each of these faces are going to be
equilateral triangles each of these
faces are equilateral triangles so if
you look so this length is the same as
that length is the same as that length
fair enough so that's our regular
tetrahedron now they say the centers of
the four faces so let's look at the
centers of the four faces let's say that
this is the center of one face this is
the center of another face
back here is the center of the face that
we can't see that's behind these two
faces and then this is the center
this right here let's say is the center
of the base the center of the four faces
are the vertices of a smaller
tetrahedron
so we could connect them and get a
smaller tetrahedron so along so we have
this one going from the center of this
face to the center of the base going
from the center of the base to the
center of this face over here we have
this line you connect those we have one
of the faces of the smaller tetrahedron
you go like that you have kind of the
top if you flipped if you flipped it
over would be the base but you have the
top of the smaller tetrahedron and then
if you connected those in the back you
would have the two faces that you can't
see that face and that face
now they want us to essentially figure
out the volume of the smaller
tetrahedron this magenta tetrahedron to
this yellow one over here
and you might already be wrecking your
brain how do you figure out the volume
of a tetrahedron what not and all of
that but the important thing to realize
the important thing to realize if you if
you take two similar
really two similar objects and if you
just know the ratio of one of their
dimensions and assuming that all of
their dimensions have the same ratio and
it is the case in this right over here
then the volume will be the cube of the
ratios of one of their sides so let me
let me
show this to you right over here let me
depict it so if we let's say
let's say that this
this length right over here let's call
that let's call that length
big for the big tetrahedron and let's
find the corresponding edge of the small
tetrahedron
so let's say that we have this
corresponding we have another small side
or we have another side of the small
tetrahedron let's call that
let's call that length small
if we know the ratio of length big to
length small if we know
if we know the ratio length big to
length small we can figure out the ratio
of the big tetrahedron we can figure out
the ratio of the big tetrahedron to the
small tetrahedron
to the
the volume of the big tetrahedron to the
volume of the small tetrahedron by just
cubing this ratio
by just cubing this ratio and we can do
that because these are completely
similar in every direction in every
dimension whatever the ratio whatever
whatever the ratio of this is to this is
the same as the ratio of that is to that
and actually all of these sides are the
same so all of these sides are going to
be the same as well so they're similar
in every dimension
so with that said we really just need to
figure out the ratio of one of the longs
one of the sides of the big tetrahedron
to the length of the side of a small
tetrahedron and to do that let's just
put ourselves and there are more elegant
ways of doing it but those get a little
bit more abstract
what i'm going to do is just try to
figure out some coordinates of some of
these vertices of the larger tetrahedron
and from that we can take the average of
the coordinates to find the coordinates
of these vertices the centers of the
faces so let me just draw
let me draw some coordinate axes here so
let's say that this is my y-axis
i'm going to try to draw it so that we
can visualize it in three dimensions so
let's say that is my y-axis
let's make
let's make my x-axis do something like
this
so let's say that is the x-axis
and then you're going to have your
z-axis go straight up and down and
actually i won't draw that yet what i
want to just draw right now is the base
of the larger tetrahedron and i'm going
to do that i'm just going to pick
arbitrary coordinates here we really
just care about the ratios we care about
the ratio so we can pick the larger
tetrahedron have any any size so let's
just say that this
let's say that that vertex right over
here is sitting is sitting right over
here this vertex sits right over here
and then this vertex this vertex right
over here sits right over there and then
let's assign let me make it so it looks
a little bit more
that looks a little bit better and so
this is the base this is the base of our
tetrahedron of our big one it's an
equilateral triangle all the sides are
the same
and just for simplicity just for
simplicity of the coordinates let's make
let's make this coordinate right over
here let's say that x is equal to one
y is clearly equal to zero because we
are on the x axis we haven't moved in
the y direction and then we haven't even
paid any attention to z but it's clearly
sitting in the x y plane so z is also
going to be equal to zero
if we go over here
if we go over here let's make this
negative one comma zero comma zero so
still on the x axis
so this distance right over here is one
this distance over here is one this
entire side is two so we also know that
this entire this entire side
over here is going to be two
and you could use 30 60 90 triangles to
figure out this distance which we need
to figure out the y coordinate here let
me be very clear this the coordinate of
this point over here x is clearly equal
to zero over here x is zero z is clearly
equal to zero we're still in the x y
plane but we don't know what the y
coordinate is so we're going to have to
do a little bit of well you could use
your knowledge of 30 60 90 triangles or
if you don't even want to do that you
can just go
straight to the pythagorean theorem
we're looking for the y-coordinate over
here we're looking for this distance
right over here this so this
y-coordinate
this y-coordinate squared plus 1 squared
is going to equal 2 squared so let me
write that over here
so this let me do a new color so this
the y coordinate squared
plus 1 squared so plus 1 is going to be
equal to 2 squared is going to be equal
to 4 where this is the y coordinate so y
squared is going to be equal to 3
y is going to be equal to the square
root of 3. so this distance right over
here is the square root of 3 or so i
could write square root of 3 here you
could see that this satisfies the
pythagorean theorem or i could just put
its coordinate
its coordinate is square root of 3 in
the y direction now while we're focusing
on the base while we're focusing on the
base of the large tetrahedron we can
right now figure out the center of that
base figure out the center of that face
which maybe might sit
right about here and the easy way to
figure out the center of the space is
literally just to average all of the
coordinates so the coordinate for this
character right over here is going to be
the average of the x's so 0 plus 1 minus
1 is 0 divided by 3 is just going to be
0 which is very clear it's sitting on
the y-axis axis it has
it it does not move in the x direction
either to the right or to the left
the y coordinate we're going to have
square root of 3 plus 0 plus 0
over 3. so that's just going to be
square root of 3
over 3. so it's one third of the way all
the way to the the top of the base and
then the z coordinate you could take the
average but it's clearly still sitting
on the x y plane so it's also going to
be zero you could say zero plus zero
plus zero divided by three clearly still
zero so we figured out also one of the
vertices of our smaller of our smaller
tetrahedron what i want to do now is try
to figure out
is to try to figure out the coordinates
of this vertex right here then we can
figure out this distance compare it to a
distance of two and then essentially
take the cube of it and we'll have our
will have the ratio we need and then we
can figure out the rest of the problem
the m plus n now to figure out to figure
out the coordinates here we need to take
the average of this coordinate this
coordinate and this coordinate up here
we know these two coordinates we know
these two coordinates we just need to
figure out this coordinate up here and
to do that let's now extend into
the z direction
so if we were to if we were to go
straight up from this point so if we
were to go straight up from that center
point that we just figured out let's say
we go right
let me i could draw a neater
altitude than that
so let's say i were to go straight up
from this point right here to the top
of this tetrahedron so let's say
tetrahedron saying it a little bit weird
so now the tetrahedron you can imagine
looks like this
this is
the drawing is the hard part here
so now this is
a face of the tetrahedron i don't even
have to draw the whole thing i think we
can visualize it
having trouble drawing it making my hand
go in an awkward position let me see let
me see if i can just draw it with dotted
lines
so that side so what i've just drawn
here is this face of the tetrahedron
i've just drawn i've just drawn this
magenta face
let me
i've just drawn this magenta face of the
tetrahedron
right over here
right over here and i think and i could
draw the back side too i could draw the
backside just like that i could draw it
over there and i think it's pretty clear
to you that this this point right here
is going to lie right on top right on
top of this center point over here so we
already know a few we already know a few
of its coordinates we know it's x and y
coordinate we just need to figure out
its z coordinate so its x coordinate is
going to be zero it's going to be the
same x coordinate here we haven't moved
along the x axis it's y coordinate is
going to be the square root of 3
over 3 same as this guy over here but
it's going to have some height in the z
direction so we need to figure out what
that is and to do that
what i'm going to do is draw is to draw
essentially an altitude for the face of
this front face i'm going to go from
this point up to here or from this point
up
up to here
so if you look at this blue line right
over here we already figured out what
this distance is all the faces it's a
regular tetrahedron so all of the faces
have the same length so this blue
distance right over here is going to be
the same as this distance over here
because this was the altitude for that
bottom face and we already figured out
that this distance over here is square
root of three we did that that's the
first thing we did that this distance
over here from this point to this point
is square root of three so this distance
is also the square root of three we also
know we also know that this distance
right over here let me do this in a new
color we also know that this distance
over here is the square root of three
over three
this is a right angle it might not be
completely obvious the way i did it but
this was an altitude so now we can
figure out
we can figure out the height
of this of the pyramid or the
tetrahedron and that height to this
point is going to be our z coordinate so
let's call that height
h so we know from the pythagorean
theorem h squared
h squared plus
the base squared right over here which
is going to be square root of 3 over 3
squared is going to be 3
over
3 over 9 is going to be equal to the
square root of 3 squared it's going to
be equal to 3. or subtracting this from
both sides we have 8 squared is equal to
all right it is i'll write the it's 3
minus 3 over 9 3 minus 1 3 which is the
same thing as 9 3 minus 1 3 which is
equal to 8 3 and so if we want to take
the square root of both sides we'll get
h is equal to square root of 8 is the
square root of 4 times square root of 2
so that's 2 square roots of 2
over the square root of 3. so that is h
and that's also the z coordinate here so
this is 2
square roots of 2
2 square roots of 2
over the square root of 3. i'm already
close to 14 minutes here
so i'm going to continue in the next
video but we now have the coordinate for
this top point so we can take the
average of these three coordinates find
the coordinate for this point right over
here then use then find the distance
between this point and this point that
we already got the coordinate for to
figure out how long this side is and
then we can compare the ratio of that to
that
cube it to get the ratio of the volumes